Mm.. now I am like senpai....
Hello everybody my name is Markiplier
And welcome back to Huniecam Studio
Now we're back in our little empire here and we've got a WHOLE bunch of fun to be had and a lot of money to be made for me, AND for them,
Even though I... kind of tricked them with the piggy bank and to the point where they're not really asking for alot more money
But that's- That's besides the point that's..that's entirely their fault, like I didn't do any of that they got the piggy bank and then they decided that they needed to be paid less.
I didn't have anything to do with it. So, enough justification about my shitty business practices is all my own, time to talk to virtual girls- actually they don't even talk to me.
And no one in real life talks to me anyway-
BUT we have a lot of work to be doing and I am actually STARTING to go low on alcohol! Because...er, er... Lola, I didn't need to pull up the name. I knew the name, Lola.
It was already up don't worry about it, I got it. Lola is gonna get a butt plug *repeats hysterically*
And then Kyanna is gonna geeeeeet... theeeeeee, "microphone".
And then, uh, Tiffany is gonna get the shopping bag, because she is gonna be my errand girl for like the entirety of this
So anyway, so they're doing all that stuff and then I'm doing this stuff, we'll get the photo shoots going on but now...
Tiffany, basically... I sometimes feel bad about things, but I dont feel too bad about this
I just kind of need her to go do things for me, I need SOMEONE to be able to go get things, that's important
That's a thing that people do, kind of, maybe (A runner, Mark. The dog.)
I'm wasting money on that 'cause I got too many of these in the way
Aw, yes please, can you go back for more? We need a lot of booze , Lola is a bit of a drinker
And later in the game you're gonna get a lot of ladies that DO drink a lot
And that is a problem because that gets in the way of a lot of things we need to do
Oh no, but Tiffany can't be my errand girl, she's good at stripping
I mean... ah man it sounds so creepy, everything that I'm doing
Oh god, just wait till I start signing them to the Sleezy Motel
Thaaat's gonna be niiice...
Everyone's gonna be happy about that, but they're gonna be SAFE
Oh and I didnt mention that. I'm not wearing my glasses because I was just recording on the..uh.. VIVE
Not the VIVE *incorrectly*,  because god, I wanna pronounce everything the wrong way
I still call this HuniePop *incorrectly*, even though it's very  obviously HuniePop, or Cam, or it's not even HuniePop, It's Hunie, its HunieCam *pronounced incorrectly*
It's HunieCam, It's always gonna be HunieCam, no one's gonna change it from being HunieCam (he's saying "hooniecam")
That is just what it is and what its always gonna be for the rest of my existence
But for now, we're still trying to run an empire here and we've  got a long way to go
Because this game ends when you hit 21 days
And when you hit 21 days you better have as many fans as you're gonna have and that includes... A LOT of work
Because holy crap there's so many things
Nah I'm not
Ughh
Ohhhh shut up, I got it, it's ok, it's fine!
Oh it's fine don't worry about it, I got it, let me smooth it over
Nooo
Come on! You can't be like that, I'm good for the money, you just gotta trust me
UHHH
(*markimoose sounds.* Don't worry, he's fine..probs..)
MMMMM
Ok, I know, I know what I've been doing, I haven't been getting, uh, I haven't been getting Nikki, my money maker, into the cam studio, and I haven't been getting alot of them into the cam studio
Because I have been waiting off on doing that because I want the value to go up only on specific people
Which means that you are, ya, you need to go to the boutique
I need to... promo, I don't have money for that. I forgot, ok, so as soon as Nikki is out of the photo shoot I gotta get her back into the cam studio to do more "let's plays"
Even though I promised that I was gonna be honest about that, It's still "let's plays" everybody hush
It's nothing bad
She needs a second item as well
She needs the subscribe pillow because that's gonna help her get more fans continually
'Cause now I'm just gonna keep her in the cam studio
And then she's just gonna go in over and over again and then I need to get the money out of it, and then she... Lola
You better... Lola better have, oh if Lola doesn't have
Oh does Lola have a piggy bank?
Ok, good! I forgot, Lola has a piggy bank and a butt plug
Everything, a- young... entrepreneurial girl needs
Butt plugs and piggy banks, anyway I'm gonna move on, I got more money- finally I'm out of the red
So that's good, because I'm out of the red at 7 a.m. which means that I got a lot of potential to do this
And so as they are getting more and more fans, I'm gonna send her to the strip club
*realizes mistake as rage slowly builds*
ALRIGHT FINE IT'S A STRIP CLUB, THEY'RE GETTING NAKED, THEY'RE GETTING NAKED ON CAMERA, HOW MANY TIMES DO I NEED TO ADMIT THIS BEFORE ITS OK TO MYSELF!?!?
*breathes in loudly* It's ok
Everything's fine
Ok we got enough money here so we can finally get more fans
*laughs* Furry, Squirting, Tattoos, and Chubby
OH BOY
Kids, close your eyes
Close your ears
Close everything you have
It's not- it's not appropriate
I gotta get more money out of this, It takes so much TIMMEE
*chewbacca sound*
Ok, yeah Nikki is making SO much money for me and that's great about it
And I gotta- I gotta go into superclick mode because we need to get outta here
And then I need to get more, more cash, I can't believe I have to spend cash just to be able to get my cash outta the cash place
It's such bullshit , outta the cash bull?
Eueh
Ok
Then Lola is waiting. Lola is doing wonderfully, but Lola needs more fans
Before I can start putting her in the Cam shows because the Cam shows progressively take more time
I said that in the last one and it is true
I wouldn't lie to you guys even though I obviously lied to you guys in the last one, but dont worry about that that's not important
Hebeda Hebeda Hebeda Hebeda Hebeda Hebeda Hebeda Hebeda Hebeda Hebeda Hebeda
Ok
There we go
Someone's relaxing
Ok, So you, are *weird sounds*
I need to get these outta here before you can do your thing
Eh, eh, eh, eh, EH, EH, EH, EH, EH, uh
Ehhh, It's a good amount of money, but it's not enough money, *raging* you need more fans
We need to buy more fans, god dammit we can't get more fans, we need to get more fans
RABARDACHEY
Ok books. How much do I owe you guys?
Ah I'll pay off right now so that I don't have to worry about it later
Ok photo shoot,  there's two people at the photo shoot
AHHHH CLICK HARDER
Ah, not enough clicking, not enough time
See this is the problem I get, I get all in a tizzy
When I need to do these things
Oh man, when did she get four and four? That's not..
32 dollars an hour for Lola!?!?
God dammit!
She doesn't have enough fans for that
Ok I gotta like, I'm gonna bench Lola, she's gonna be on the back burner for a while, because I accidentally got her up to four and four, which is DEFINITELY not what I meant to do
If anything I need to get Nikki up to another avenue of.....
Uh, strip pole..strip poling?
Strip pole, and stadoing, eee uhhh, don't worry about it, it's fine
At least she's getting more fans here
Then I just need to basically get all of her...
Uhh
All of her work is gonna be off of..
....
Getting fans from the Internet
And that's gonna be the main priority of it
But fiiirrrsst
Oh cake, oh my god, euehh
If anyone didn't know, the cake supports, the cake farting fetish
And
I don't know about you guys
I would like to keep my innocence for just a little bit longer and not have to worry about that
But everyone's gotta grow up sometime, so we're gonna get a cake and then someone's gonna be
Doing
The cake farting...
*weird voice* Cake farts
I mean... I didnt even watch that video until It was  mentioned on Game Grumps
I knew about the video, don't get me wrong I'm not that innocent
I knew about the video very easily
But the only problem was
...
I didn't watch it until after I was watching the Game Grumps talk about it
And
They built it up in my mind that it was like- some- REALLY mid-western accent
Uh
Like
Like...
*mark's mid-western accent* it's cake farts..
Let's get this done
So I was building it up in my mind that it was gonna be something a lot funnier than it actually was
And it just turned out to be very gross...
Kids don't even... don't even look any of this up
*cat eating cake*?    MEOW
Now we're starting to make good money but we gotta make a looot more than this, we gotta make a lot more
Now's the money rush because now OFFICIALLY the fans have out-paced
Uh
Getting them on our own
So getting them on our own doesn't even matter
The good thing about
Uh
Nikki doing cam shows is that she gets "extra special bonuses"
And then eventually they will have more items and then fans will like overlap more with the different
"fetishes"
"fetis"
*cough*
"FETISHES"
"THE FETISHES!!"
Then hopefully
'THE FETISHES!"
Will be
Appropriate for people..to..understand
Anyway
Gotta get more
Gotta get more to make more
(Damaging his wrist "clicking" his "mouse")
Gotta click harder
Gotta click better!
Gotta click faster!
Gotta clich
Click
Ok
Kyanna you need to get...
Oh shit
What do you need to do?
You need to recruit another, because we're gonna need another person in here very soon...
Tiffany, go back into the shop
You're in there
GREEAAAATTTT
We're making so much muns (for the funs, am I right??!?)
Ok get that
That
Ok
In there
Dammit
Stop stressin'  Nikki it's fineeee
You're just showin' your..
Ba, boobs
To everybody on the internet, it's totally cool don't worry about it it's fineeee
Ok
Go go go
Yeah I know, I know, I know, I know, I know, I know
More, more, more
You need, ah, you need to relax I guess
Ah, come one
HURRY UP WITH THE RELAXING
WE GOT WORK TO DO
YOU GOTTA SHOW YOUR
"boobs"
TO EVERYBODY ON THE INTERNET
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
UHHH
The fairy lady is gonna be don my ass?
Don?
She's gonna don my ass?
Real good, if you don't hurry up
Ok
We're gonna need another girl
We need this to get more
We need that
We need the cheap ones
And thennn....
Yeah..
That should do
Ok
What did you do Lola?
Lola what did you dooo?
I don't know what you did but we need more fans
But we need more money
But we can officially get another girl
Hellooo
HIII
Oh I changed Jessie's outfit
And Beli!
Oh
Beli's there!
But there's also Zoey
Zoey's one of the new characters that came in this game
And...
I don't really know much about her?
I mean
Her
Characteristics are Ebony and flat chest, and the Asian chubby
I guess Indian does count as Asian
MILF and chubby
I never considered Jessie to be chubby
But
Anyway, the descriptions gotta be what they are, it's the developers not me, I'm not judging anybody
We need to coordinate here
The only problem with Jessie
Is that she is addicted to both smoking and drinking
And she consumes those very quickly
But she doesn't get stressed very much, which is also a good thing
So
I...
And she's also already trained so I can just give her a piggy bank and then she's gonna be cheaper
So I'm gonna do that
HI JESSIE
How are ya doin'?
Your daughter's here too
Don't think I forgot about that weird quincidencidencts
Ok
So we're gonna give you
A piggy bank and coke
We'll save the butt plug for a little bit later
And then we'll worry about this right now
Ok
So now it's official that she can make a lot of money
Alright
Ok
I just gotta
I just gotta condom
And the condom
Is used for
*cough*
"Being safe"
And
Being safe is very important
It is...
It's very important
Veeryy Important..
Veerryy Important
Because
There is a Sleazy Motel over there
Where you can send your girls to... * nervously trying to (and failing to) explain*
Uh * mark desperately trying to rationalize*
Where you can send your girls to... *worried for all the parents out there who are experiencing this*
Oink
Uhhh
Boink
Oink Boink Boink
Ok
So this is good because we got
we got more fans
and the fan, actually you can see in the menu
The fans have a certain distribution
And because...
I have been really been pushing Nikki forward
She has glasses
And
HUUGGE BOOBS
HUGGE BOOBS
A lot of the fans like that stuff
But
As I've been buying them, a lot of fans like other things too
So because Lola has a butt plug..
She likes that
And eventually
There will be more overlap as things go on
And then I will get that taken care of
And that's all good
And we'll get there
But for right now, we just need to worry about what we got right here
And eventually once I start making even more money once I got so many fans
I can get rid of the piggy banks
Because pay won't even matter
And then I can get more people on the fans
So that's like a late game strategy
Cause like
I dont know why I'm strategizing for you guys
But this is how this works
This is how I think
I'm gonna get rid of this
Discard that
And I'm gonna give her...
We have...
Oh
Yeah we have actually have a good number of furry fans
So
Lets give that to Kyanna
She'll have some more fans, she'll make some more money going into that'll be good
It'll be
Good, good, good, good, good, good
I just gotta get alot more of this goin' on here
Come on Tiffany we need a Booze run
TTIFFANNNY
Alright
There we go
You're done there
You go back
Oh god cake farts
*mark's mid-western accent* cake farts
Cake fartttss
Might as well
I guess
My goal at the end of this is to have everyone...
With the cake farts
Ok, making more money more money more money
AND, done
Good job
Getting there making more myuns
MAKE MORE MYUNEY
WE NEED LOT MORE MONEY
NEED ALL MORE MONEY
All of the moneys
Ok so youuu
Actually
You have a good number of fans
So you can start going in there
'Cause we can have three people in there at once
Right now...
EMMMRRAA
I'm clicking so good
Ok, get right back in there
Get right back in there
We need
Ok
So thaaats
Euuh
Euuuh
Euh
Let's get another condom
CAUSE WE CAN ALWAYS USE THOSE FOR SOME REASON
NOBODY ASK WHY..
Ok
Before the next day I wanted to get this, which is the new advertising slot which is gonna open up alot of opportunities for
USSS
Here we go
More people doing a cam show
Ok you go back, right in there
Alright everything is working out wonderfully
Everything is working out delightfully
Ok
Go right back in
MONEY MONEY MONEY MONEY MONEY
ITS LITERALLY ALL I CARE ABOUT
I cant even pay everybody off
Man I bought a lot of upgrades so that means that we're running low on money for this
But
That's totally fine
Ok
You need way more
You need to get...
Alright, get more of that
Piece of cake, funny you mention that
We're gonna need you to take this cake and go into the room and then just
You know...
Do whatever feels natural...I suppose
Eugh
So pretty soon we actually need to send someone in to go recruit another girl
'Cause we need one more to join our
Repertoire
See that like
It didn't even matter
That was like insignificant
And we got a whole bunch of potential fans here for this stuff
So we just
Get em' all up here
We basically just want as many fans as possible, like no matter what we want fans
Ok you
10 hours, jeez
Ah, too much time, you're too expensive
WHY ARE YOU SO EXPENSIVE!?
It's not good
Whatever
Smart move I know, thanks bro
I don't know how I'm doing, I actually feel like I'm doing very poorly
'Cause usually in perspecitve of everything else I've been doing I can get a good judge on how far I'm coming along
But
I have a funny feeling I'm not doing it perfectly well
I'm just gonna get her in the modeling agency so i can have that on the way
Uh huh I know
See the good thing about It is when you take time off of them in the cam studio or them working you can actually save money
Uh based on how much time you chop off, because they're paid by the hour
But
If you reduce the thing down a few hours, you will pay them less
So that's good
Alright so weee
Need the three items
Thats gonna be even better because now we can start spreading out the different items that they have even better
Because she had a subscribe pillow, but I'm gonna take that off now because we don't need that anymore
Because now...
The number of fans that she is gonna get from other sources is always gonna be better
So...
Eughhuh
Euhh
Ewwslsuuh
It looks like bondage is the next big one
So I'm gonna do that
I guess...
I'll just give her...
Nikki you're gonna have a butt plug too
Have fun with that
Good luck
Take luck and have luck
Have luck to take luck
Ok, you already got those so you need something else
Uhhhh
Alright you get
You get a cake
I don't know how many cake farters we have here but Its gonna be good enough
Ok
So
That is all the time I have for this episode, we are making a good bit of progress we got a few, like, we have 12 days left, so I know we can get to the end of this before everything goes horribly tits up
Not in the good way
So thank you everybody so much for watching
And as always
I will see you
In the next video
BYE BYE!
Subscribe to Markiplier if you haven't already! He's actually really cool, I swear. (Don't hold me to that.)
Subtitling by various people. Who knows.
meow